die habe ich lass uns irgendwo bei
facebook oder so wie sie in unserem
video gibt's denn sowas habe ich seine
hand manchmal werden träume hat einfach
was meinst du ja man sitzt hat irgendwo
im youtube nicht gelungen eine äußerst
knapp und herzlich willkommen bei einem
neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut mir auch
danke wir haben heute was spezielles vor
und zwar habe ich die möglichkeit
bekomme dafür absolut kein geld oder so
ich fand es ist aber eigentlich ein sehr
interessantes konzept und auch ein
cooles konzepte zuschauerin hat mich
darauf hingewiesen dass es diesen
anbieter gap die nennt sich irgendwie
ich kann es euch hier mal kurz zeigen
macbooks und dahinter versteckt sich
jeden monat sondern box die kriegt man
dann halt nach hause zugeschickt mit
süßigkeiten essens möglichkeiten nämlich
erstens möglichkeiten generell essen und
trinken aus der ganzen welt
also wir haben jetzt hier die erste box
und da sind nur produkte aus einem
bestimmten land drin welches land das
ist weiß ich an dieser stelle nicht das
macht das ganze umso spannender also ich
werde dir jetzt vielleicht zum ersten
mal auf machen sich aber auch absolut
keine ahnung was da drin ist aber wir
packen wir zusammen aus und ich bin
wirklich mal gespannt an dieser stelle
auf jeden fall dank an euch dass wir
hier so ein paar boxen geschickt habe da
wird es jetzt in zukunft auf jeden fall
öfter mal ein video zu geben wo ich dann
so eine box aufmache und die sachen die
da drin sind testen und so erste
eindruck ist auf jeden fall schon mal
ganz gut oder dass wir zusammen kann man
machen
keine schöne box auf jeden fall das bin
ich war umso gespannter wenn dieses land
wie hier drin haben weil so ein land
werde habe ich bisher auch so irgendwas
auch von einer ganz anderen seite der
welt weist das glaube ich interessant
weil alle länder sind ja so verschieden
auch was essen angeht und hier haben ach
ich hab schon gesehen und zwar haben wir
hier eigentlich interessant für die
erste folge japan also wir sind jetzt
ganz viele süßigkeiten oder was auch
immer aus japan drin machst du dafür ist
achso hier bestellt ist steht sogar zu
allem was da drin ist irgendwie so eine
info beweist
ich hab mir grad schon gesehen da gibt's
immer dass hier das sind so sieht so aus
wie so gebackene shrimps oder so eine
der faktor erstmal jetzt wohl einfach
nur ein my swag also das ist das erste
dann haben wir hier die kann ich aber
aus deutschland oder die gibt es ja auch
in deutschland diese co
ja sie sind eigentlich kreis von dieser
cola sorte habe ich auch ich weiß dass
es die halt in deutschland gibt altern
als durchsichtige coleman junge geil ich
würde sagen ich wollte immer ein produkt
ausprobieren das sage ich dann meine
meinung dazu und dann machen wir weiter
wir haben bestimmte 12 13 also hier
haben wir meist mit karamell
ok also wahrscheinlich so wenig gekauft
worden es riecht auf jeden fall also ich
das stelle ich mir so richtig
japanischen gehört ganz klar noch mal in
china das berichten
kennst du das mal eine so wir ein dass
wir erst werde rum wo wir mal aber
probiere jetzt mal nicht gut
also stimmt eigentlich in deutschland
nicht schmecken gesund bist du doch sehr
ungesund aber das werk gibt popcorn
eigentlich nur mit richtig viel zucker
und ein bisschen knusprig aber an sich
eigentlich wirklich interessant machen
wir weiter hier wird das sind diese das
gibt es auch in deutschland
aber hier haben wir eine irgendwie so
eine andere füllung drin die koala
während nehmen euch direkt also hier ist
halt erdbeeren und nicht dieses schoko
wie man sie aus deutschland hin
das ist ja auch eine andere form die wir
in deutschland haben
aber das ist eine geschichte da hat man
dauernd schule aber keine ahnung also
ich finde die mit schokolade drin besser
machen wir mal weiter
ich habe es gerade schon gesehen ich
musste ja nicht direkt probieren weil
vielleicht bleibt länger
wir haben einfach durchsichtige kohl hat
die habe ich lass uns irgendwo bei
facebook oder so wir sehen unseren
wieder und ich dachte wo gibt's denn
sowas
jetzt habe ich selber in der hand und
zwar werden träume halt einfach war das
denkmal die flasche die ist auch einfach
heftig wenn mann und ich frage mich so
ist hier dann auch koffein drin oder ist
das einfach nur so ein getränk von coca
cola glaubt das färbemittel ist halt
einfach nicht dabei das ist genauso
schmeckt ein bisschen aber es ist ja
klar ein bisschen nach limette halt die
sprite denke ich mal aber dann schmeckt
ja nicht nach cola okay wir werden sehen
machen wir am ende was ist das denn also
die haben auf jeden fall sehr sehr
ausgefallene und von der verpackung her
sehr aufwendige süßigkeiten das sind
gummibärchen wassermelonen geschmack
können wir das sind kleine wassermelonen
ready
die sind schon heftig problem aber schon
künstlich künstlich kommen so in grand
rapids im jahr
wassermelonen geschmack bei so vielen
wäre ich nicht so den gästen kamen für
die vollkosten also ich finde er ist
eigentlich also gefällt mir richtig gut
kann ich öfter ist und gibt es hier nun
also ich muss sagen bis jetzt bin ich
auf jeden fall sehr zufrieden es ist
wirklich interessant das jetzt mal zu
sehen
wir haben jetzt komme es gibt in japan
sogar auf schokolade hier haben wir wenn
ich das jetzt nur lesen könnte dann
könnt ihr euch sagen was das ist aber
vom bild her sieht es aus wie
schokoladen diese mikado sogar genau wie
mikado sticks nur mit ein bisschen
haselnuss zwischen oder so anscheinend
probier doch mal interessant
es schmeckt irgendwie total neutral so
anders schmeckt nicht krass nach
schokolade wie man sich das eigentlich
bei solchen sachen würden also ich finde
man merkt die so richtig
kulturelle unterschiede allein schon von
dieser verpackung sowohl die die darauf
wert legt also das ist wie krass dass
sie alles eingepackt ist wie passt diese
farben sind und auch so die geschmäcker
die sind halt einfach anders als wir sie
hier in deutschland gewohnt sind wie das
funktionieren kann warum gummibärchen
aus japan anders bringt als gummibärchen
in deutschland ich habe keine ahnung
aber es ist also oder auch schokolade
schmeckt ganz anders als hier gilt es
ausprobieren und in ordnung natürlich
kannst du die schokolade nicht so stark
schmerzt dann können wir auch als
nächstes haben wir
man denkt sich jetzt so da ist bestimmt
ein dicker schokoriegel drin
aber es gibt halt einfach gar nichts
mini bürger wo habt ihr schon mal den
bekannten japanischen ja salat ist das
ist eine meist stange also hier ist
jetzt meist stangen als süßigkeit
verpackt
wer ist denn das recht auf jeden fall
sowie chips so richtig so stelle ich mir
japanische snacks vor genauso nicht
anders also es ist brutal die jüngst es
schmeckt sehr intensiv nach chips also
richtig krankheit chips geschmack und
das ist halt einfach eingepackt wie ein
schokoriegel kommt aber ich feiere ist
also bis juni sei gerade er hat sich für
diese flasche schon auf ebay
interessiert und hat sie dort für zehn
euro gefunden sondern zu teuer zu teuer
deutlich zu teuer also ich würde auch
keine zehn euro bezahlen also für ein
bisschen was zu trinken aber
liebhaberpreis liebhaber heißt es im ok
machen wir weiter das hier ist die
nächste meist standen also schmeckt auch
das ist wahrscheinlich das gleiche
deswegen tue ich das jetzt erstmal
beiseite sonst wird mir gleich schlecht
wir haben nicht eben von müllermilch
sorten probiert 13 stück boom
hintereinander ja eine sache die mich
die ganze zeit schon an lächelt danach
probieren wir dann auch mal die bruder
ist das hier bereiter gibt dir mal bitte
genau hier drauf an die knights aus oder
einen lolli mitführen oder so ich weiß
es nicht ich mache das jetzt mal auf und
hier ist wohl so ein ganzes set dritter
hätte man zero irgendwie so komische
kugeln aus zucker und ein stäbchen zum
aufgießen und eine dazu kommt dann auch
dieser ahornsirup kriege ich denn jetzt
hier raus bist du ja ansatz kann
irgendwo im job
das ist gleich viel wie ich das hier
schon lecker guck mal gemacht
jetzt ist man hier diese kugel auf tun
die in den ahorn sirup tun sie tun sie
hier in die kugeln und dann aber und das
ist eine ganz neue geschmäcker die ich
hier wird auf nehme ich glaube ich noch
nie in meinem leben so geschmeckt
bisserl gewöhnungsbedürftig aber kann
man schon feiern
das projekt das ja ungefähr also nach
rechts aus und ich habe es wirklich ich
habe keine ahnung das schmeckt so ich
weiß es nicht kann ich nicht beschreiben
ist weg wie eine süßigkeit um hier rein
und hier rein das hat die konsistenz
eines kaugummis mehr kann ich dazu nicht
sagen ich weiß nicht was schmeckt mir
leid nicht einfach irgendwas aber ist in
ordnung die beschreiben dass hier die
schau gummikugeln afl sie rund 8 also
ich würde noch abfällig habe eben ahorn
gelesen story und sträucher sind ja ich
möchte nach apfel und nach irgendwelchen
anderen sachen die ich noch nie in
meinem leben geschmeckt habe das
probieren
gut jetzt hab ich versprochen machen wir
mit der kohle weiter also wir haben hier
wirklich glasklare kohler als
risikolimit bisschen bis jetzt bald so
richtig viele leute und einer der
spannendsten momente meines lebens
es ist einfach so anders wie ich kann
sich bislang also ich weiß nicht ob es
gut finden sondern ich möchte es dann
wie cola so ein bisschen aber es
schmeckt auch wie es breit und wie
müssen mal probieren mir ist eigentlich
gut schmeckt wie cola wasser als cola
wasser als diese geschmolzen dann ein
bisschen sprudel drin also kann man woll
feiern also kann die euren bringen das
mal zu probieren eine sache haben dann
noch und zwar das ist halt so bis
komisch alle sachen man denkt okay das
liegt doch jetzt bestimmt so 300 gramm
passt hier drin ist wenn ihr jetzt
schokolade drin war 300 gramm okay aber
es sind halt einfach es wird halt
einfach gar nix also jetzt lese ich euch
mal den text dazu vor
diese süße sünde hier kommt als fisch
daher
die knusprigen waffeln kekse außen
werden von einer herrlichen und cremigen
schokoladen füllung zusammengehalten die
kombi aus schokolade und knuspriger
waffe geht halt einfach immer also es
ist halt anscheinend so eine art schoko
keks kann man das war es auch schon
und für so was so eine riesen verpackung
da sollen wir mal irgendwann deutschland
sagen wir wir sind hier wir produzieren
ist zu viel plastik oder die politik
erkennt was ist das hier spitze für ein
kreisligist ohne verpackung also diesen
geschmack habe ich auf jeden fall
schonmal geschmeckt wie schmeckt
wirklich so nach so einer trocken waffe
mit ein bisschen show zwischen ist
wahrscheinlich in japan so volle voll
der renner grad richtig im trend
in japan gibt so eine studie alle zwei
sekunden steckt sich jemand wissen die
leute das war's mit dem ersten partie zu
ich bin wirklich gespannt ich habe noch
ganz viele andere boxen von denen die
ich noch ausprobieren werde also nochmal
danke an euch snack box schöne grüße und
abonnierten kanal blogger aktivieren wir
sehen uns dann morgen um 19 uhr gibt's
neues video
haut rein